i'm a big fan of joe rogan i've been on
his show twice and whatever when francis
collins was in his
conversation with you
he said um which i think makes sense is
that when somebody has that kind of
platform and people rightly or wrongly
who follow them and look to them for
guidance
i do think
that there is some responsibility for
people in those roles
to make whatever judgment um that they
make and to share that and um as i
mentioned to you when we were off mike
uh sanjay gupta is a very close friend
of mine we've been friends for many
years and i and i fully supported
sanjay's instinct to go on the
on the joe rogan show i thought it was
yeah it was great
at the end of that whole conversation
joe said well i'm just a comedian what
do i know and i just felt that
yes joe rogan is a comedian i wouldn't
say
just a comedian among among other things
but i also felt that he had a
responsibility
for just saying whatever he believed
even if he believed or believes as i
think is the case
that uh ivermectin should be studied
more which i certainly agree
um and that you know healthy people
shouldn't get vaccinated healthy young
people which i don't agree i just felt
at the end of that conversation to say
well i'm just a comedian what do i know
i feel like it it it didn't fully
integrate
the power that a person like joe rogan
has to set the agenda so i think
the reason he says i'm just comedian is
the same reason i say i'm an idiot which
i truly believe i could explain exactly
what i mean by that but like
it's it's it's more for him or in this
case for me
to just keep yourself humble not you
know because i think
it's a slippery slope when you think you
have a responsibility to then
think you actually have an authority
because a lot of people listen to you
you think you have an authority to
actually like speak to those people and
you have the enough authority to know
what the hell you're talking about and i
think there's just the humility to just
kind of making fun of yourself
that's extremely valuable and saying i'm
just a comedian
and i think it's a reminder to himself
that uh
you know
he's often full of [ __ ]
so are all of us and so
that's a really powerful way for himself
to keep himself humble
i mean i i think that's really useful to
in some kind of way for people in
general to
um yeah make fun of themselves a little
bit in whatever way that means and
saying i'm just a comedian is just one
way to do that now that that coupled
that with the responsibility of doing
the research and really having an open
mind and all those kinds of stuff
i think that's something joe does really
well on a lot of topics
but he can't do that and everything and
so that
it's up to the people to decide how well
he does it on on certain topics and and
not others
um but how do you think sanji did in
that conversation so i know i'm gonna
get myself into trouble here um because
sanjay's a very close friend
joe
my personal interaction with him has
been our two interviews but it's like my
interview with now you sit down with
somebody for four hours it's it's a lot
and and and grade and then and then
private
uh communication so i am personally more
sympathetic now to the arguments
that sanjay was making or trying uh
trying to make i believe
that the threat of the virus is greater
than the threat of the vaccine that
doesn't mean that we can guarantee 100
safety
for the vaccine but these are
really well tolerated vaccines and we
know for all the reasons we've been
talking about this is a really scary
virus and particularly the mrna vaccines
what they're basically doing is getting
your body to replicate a tiny little
piece of the virus the spike protein and
then your body
responds to that and so that's a much
less much less of an insult to your body
than being infected by the virus so i'm
i'm more sympathetic to the people who
say well everybody should get vaccinated
um but people who've already been
infected we should study whether they
need to be vaccinated uh or not
having said all of that um i felt that
um
uh that joe rogan won the debate i mean
it was and the reason that i felt that
he won the debate was there were they
were kind of
had they had two different categories of
arguments so sanjay
what he was trying to do which i totally
respect was saying there's so much
animosity between the on these different
sides let's lower the temperature let's
let's model that we can have a
respectful dialogue with each other
where we can actually listen and sanjay
again i've known him for many years he's
a very empathic humble
just a
all-around wonderful human being and i
really love him and so he was making
cases that were based on kind of
averages studies and things like that
and joe was saying well i know a guy
whose sister's cousin had this
experience
and i'm sure that it's all true in the
sense that we have millions of people
who are getting vaccinated and and
different things
and what sanjay should have said was i i
know that's anecdote here's another
anecdote of like when francis collins
was with you and he talked about the
world wrestling guy who was like six six
and a big muscly guy and then he got
coveted and he was anti-vaxxer and then
he got coveted and almost died and he
said i'm gonna by the way yeah i don't
know if you know this part no oh this is
funny joe's going to listen to this he's
going to be laughing does joe listen
like to the four hours of this in
addition to the three hours of his
interviews every day no not every day
but he listens to a lot of these
and we talk about it we argue about it
hi joe
we love you joe
but he uh so that particular case
i don't know why francis said what he
said there
but that's not accurate oh really so the
wrestler
never
he didn't almost die he was no big deal
at all for him and he said that to him i
think
i'm not sure i think something got mixed
up in francis's memory he there was
another case he must have been like
because i don't imagine he would bring
that case up and just like make it up
you know because like why
but he that was not at all like that's a
pretty public case he had an interview
with him that uh that wrestler he was
just fine so that anecdotal case
i mean francis should not have done that
so if i have any so i have a bunch of
criticism of how that went
people who criticized that interview
i feel like don't give enough
respect to the full range of things that
francis collins has done in his career
here's an incredible scientist and i
also think a really good human being
but uh yes that conversation was flawed
in many ways and one of them was
why
when you're
trying to present some kind of critical
like criticize joe rogan
why bring up adult evidence at all and
if you do bring up anecdotal evidence
which is not scientific if you're
scientists you should not be using
anecdotal evidence if you do bring it up
why bring up one that's not
that's first not true and you know it's
not true well it's nice i just remember
so i know pretend so you don't know it's
not your
so yes that would have been
find another case exactly uh where
exactly so the basic thing in it coming
back to sanjay and and joe's uh
conversation was that sanjay was trying
to use statistical evidence and joe was
using anecdotal evidence and so i think
that
for sanjay and there are all kinds of of
things where there are debates where the
often the person who's better at
debating wins the debate regardless of
the topic
um so i think what what sanjay could
have done and sanjay's such a smart a
smart guy
is to say well that's
that's an anecdote here's another
anecdote and there are lots of different
anecdotes and there certainly are people
who have taken the vaccine and have had
problems that could reasonably be traced
to the vaccines and there are certainly
are lots of people i would argue more
people who've not had the vaccine but
who've gotten coveted and have either
died or our hospitals are now full of
people who weren't vaccinated in many
ways i mean our emergency rooms are full
of unvaccinated people here in the
united states so i think what sanjay
could have done but there was a conflict
between
wanting to kind of
win the debate
and wanting to take the temperature down
and yeah what he could have done
is to say well here's an anecdote i have
a counter anecdote and we can go on all
day but here's what the statistics show
and i think that was
the the things i think it's it's a
healthy conversation we can't i mean
there are a lot of people
who are
afraid of the vaccine there are a lot of
people who don't trust the scientific
establishment and lots of them have good
reason it's not just uh people think of
like trump republicans there are lots of
of people in the african-american
community
um who've had a historical terrible
experience um with the tuskegee and and
all sorts of things so they they don't
trust the messages that were being
delivered i live in in new york city
and they had a we had a piece in the new
york times where in the in the earliest
days of the vaccines there was this big
movement let's make sure
that the poorest people in the city have
first access to the vaccines because
they're the ones they have higher
density in their homes they're relying
on public transport so there's this
whole liberal effort let's and then
in the black community in new york
according to the new york times there
was very low acceptance of the vaccines
and they interviewed people in that
article and they said
well if the white people want us to have
it first
there must be something wrong with it
they must be doing something
and so we have to listen to each other
the like i would never
i i have a disrespect for everybody and
if somebody is cautious
about the vaccine for themselves or or
for their children we have to listen to
that at the same time
public health is about creating public
health and there's no doubt i think
joe was absolutely right
that older people
obese people
are at greater risk for being harmed or
killed by the by covet 19 than young
healthy people
but
by everybody getting vaccinated we
reduce the risk to everybody else and so
i i feel like like with everything
there's the individual benefit argument
and then there's the community argument
and i absolutely think but expressing
that clearly that there's a difference
between the individual
health and uh freedoms and uh the
community health and freedoms and
express steel manning each side of this
is this one of the problems that people
don't do enough of
is be able to so how do you steal man an
argument
you describe that argument the best
possible way
you have to first understand that
argument let's go to the
non-controversial thing like flat earth
like most people most colleagues of mine
at mit
don't even
read about
like the the full argument that the flat
earthers make
i feel is disingenuous
for people in the physics community
to roll their eyes at flat earthers if
they haven't read their arguments
you should
you should feel bad that you don't read
their arguments and like like the it's
the rolling of the eyes
that's a big problem you haven't read it
your intuition says that these are a
bunch of crazy people okay but you don't
get you you haven't earned the right to
roll your eyes you've earned your right
to maybe
not read it
but then don't have an opinion don't
roll your eyes don't do any of that
dismissive stuff and the same thing in
this the the scientific community around
covet and so on there's often this kind
of saying oh god that's conspiracy
theories that's misinformation without
actually looking into what they're
saying if you haven't looked into what
they're saying then don't talk about it
like if you're a scientific leader and
the communicator you need to look into
it it's not that much effort i totally
agree and i think that humility it's a
it's a constant theme of your podcast
and i love that and so after the the uh
conversation debate whatever it was
between sanjay and joe
i reached out on twitter to someone i've
never met in person but i'm in in touch
privately to a guy named daniel griffin
who's a a professor at uh at columbia uh
medical school and just so smart there
he's uh he gives regular updates on
covet 19 on a thing called um twiv this
week in virology i'm a people i'm a
critic of twiv for its its coverage of
academic origins yes um but on this
issue i'm just having regular updates
daniel is great and so i said
to him i said why don't we
have a
an honest process
to get the people who are raising
concerns about the vaccines in their own
words to raise what are their concerns
and then um let's do our best job of
saying well here are these concerns
and then here is um our evidence making
a counter claim and here are links to if
you want to look at the studies upon
which these claims are made here here
they are and daniel who's incredibly
busy i mean he he reads every
i mean it seems every paper that comes
out every week and it's unbelievable um
so but he sent me a link to the cdc
q a page
on on the cdc website and it wasn't that
it was people who were i mean it was
written by people like me who were
convinced in the benefit
of these
of these vaccines so the questions
were framed they were kind of like they
weren't really the framing of the people
with the concerns they were framing of
people who were just kind of imagining
something else i mean you always talk
about kind of humility and active
listening
i know you don't mean and it doesn't
mean that we don't stand for something
like i i certainly am a strong proponent
of vaccines and masks and and all of
those things
um but if we don't hear
the other people we don't let if we
don't let them hear their voice
in the conversation if it's just saying
well you may think this and here's why
it's wrong
the argument may be right it'll just
never break through by the way my
interpretation of joe and sanjay i
listened to that conversation without
looking at twitter or the internet and i
thought that was a great conversation
and i thought sanji actually really
succeeded bringing the temperature down
to me the goal was bringing the
temperature down i didn't even think of
it as a debate i was like oh cool this
isn't going to be some weird it's like
two friendly people talking and then i
look at the internet and then the
internet says joe rogan slams like like
as if as if there was a heated debate
that joe won and it's like all right
it's really the temperature being
brought down
real conversation between two humans
that wasn't really a debate
it was just a conversation yeah and that
was a success yeah i i definitely think
it was a success
but i also felt um that
um
that
a takeaway but and again this isn't
because this is something that i don't
agree with even though i have great as
i've said respect for joe i think a
reasonable person
listening to that conversation would
come away with the conclusion that um
all in all these vaccines are a good
thing um but
if you're young and healthy
you probably don't need it
and i just felt that um
that there was a stronger case
to be made even though sanjay made it it
wasn't that sanjay didn't make it it was
just that in the flow of that
conversation
i felt that the case
for
the vaccines
and the vaccines both as an individual
choice and then certainly again as i
said before i think that while people
can be afraid of the vaccines the virus
itself is much scarier and we're just
we're seeing it now in in in real time
now with these
variations and variants
i just felt that that was kind of the
the rough takeaway from that
conversation
um
and i felt that that sanjay again whom i
love i felt like could have made his
case a little bit uh so the way the
thing he succeeded is he didn't come off
as a
like
a science expert looking down
at everybody talking down to everybody
so he succeeded in that yeah which is
very respectful but i also think sort of
making the case for taking the vaccine
where you when you're a young healthy
person
when you're sitting across from joe
rogan
is like a
high difficulty on the video game level
for sure so it's not um
it's difficult to do yeah it's difficult
to do and also it's difficult to do
because it's not like
it's not as simple
as like look at the data there's a lot
of data to go through here yeah and
there's also a lot of non-data stuff
like
the fact that first of all uh
questioning the sources of the data the
quality of the data right there's it's
also disappointing about covet is that
the quality of the data is not great but
also questioning
all the
uh motivations of the different parties
involved whether it's major
organizations that develop the vaccine
whether it's major institutions like nih
or nyad that that are sort of
communicating to us about the vaccine
whether it's the cdc and the who
whether it's the buying or the trump
administration whether it's china and
all those kinds of things you have to
that's part of the conversation here i
mean vaccination is not just a public
health tool it's also a tool for a
government to gain more control over the
populace
like there's a lot of truth to that too
things that have a lot of benefit
can also be used as a trojan horse
to increase bureaucracy and control
but those that has to be on the table
for a conversation yeah i i think it has
to be on the conversation but
um i mean your parents in when they were
in the soviet union and here in the
united states and actually was a big
collaboration between us and soviet
union
when the polio vaccine came out but
there were people all around the world
who had a different life trajectory no
longer living in fear and all of these
people who were paralyzed or killed from
polio smallpox has been eradicated it
was one of the the great successes in
human history and while it for sure is
true that you could imagine some kind of
fraudulent
um vaccination effort
but here i i genuinely think i mean
whatever the number 15 million 16
million is the economist number of dead
from covet 19
many many many more people would be dead
but for these vaccines and so i get that
any activity that needs to be
coordinated by a central government has
the potential to increase bureaucracy
and increase
control
but there are certain things that
central governments do
like the development particularly these
mrna vaccines which it's it's purely a a
us government victory i mean it was
huge darpa funding and then uh ni the
national institute for allergy and
infectious disease nih
funding i mean this was a public-private
partnership throughout and that we got a
working vaccine in 11 months was a
miracle so like it's not purely a
victory
again you have to be open-minded
i'm i'm with you here playing a bit of
devil's advocate but the people who
discuss antiviral drugs like gabermectin
and other alternatives would say that
the extreme focus on the vaccine
distracted us from considering other
possibilities
and saying that this is purely a success
is distracting from the story that there
could have been other solutions so yes
it's a huge success that the vaccine was
developed so quickly
and
surprisingly way more effective than it
was
hoped for
but there could have been other
solutions and they completely distracted
from us
from that in fact it distracted us from
looking into a bunch of things like the
lab leak and so it's not a pure victory
and fair enough and there's a lot of
people that criticize the overreach of
government and all of this
one of the things that makes the united
states great
is the individualism
and the hesitancy to ideas of mandates
even if the mandates on mass will have a
positive
even strongly positive result
the
americans many americans will still say
no
because
in the long arc of history
saying no in that moment will actually
lead to
a better country and a better world so
that's a messed up aspect of america
but it's also a beautiful part we're
skeptical
even about good things
i agree and and certainly
we should all be cautious about
government overreach absolutely and it
happens in all kinds of scenarios with
incarceration with a thousand things
and we also should be afraid of
government under reach that if there is
a problem that could be solved by
governments and that's why we have
governments in the first place is that
there's just certain things that
individuals can't do on their own and
that's why we we pool our resources and
we in some ways um sacrifice our rights
for this common thing and that's why we
don't have
hopefully people murderers marauding or
people driving 200 miles down the street
that we we have a process for arriving
at a set of common rules and so well i
fully agree that we need to respect and
we need to listen
um we need to find that right balance
and you you've raised the magic eye word
ivermectin um
and so on ivermectin
like my view has always been um
ivermectin could be effective it could
not be effective
let's study it through a full process
and when you had francis collins with
you even while he was making up stories
about this
this wrestler um he was saying
exactly but he was he was saying that
they're going to do a full randomized
highest level trial of ivermectin and if
ivermectin works then that's another
tool in our in our toolbox and i think
we we should and i think that in that
sanjay was absolutely correct
to concede the point to joe
um that it was disingenuous for people
including people on cnn uh to say that
ivermectin is is um is for livestock and
so i
like i definitely think that we have to
like we have to have some kind of
process that allows us to come together
and i totally agree that the great
strength of
america is that we empower individuals
it's the history of our frontier
mentality in our country so we
i 100 agree that we have to allow that
even if sometimes it creates messy
processes and uncomfortable feelings and
all those sorts of things
you